.
>> HERE'S MY VISION, IT JUST
CAME TO ME.
PICTURE THE BORDER, WE BUILD A
WALL, WE'VE BUILT A TALL, BIG --
A BEAUTIFUL WALL.
WE HAVE THE WALL GO FOR MILES.
>> Greg: IT'S A SHAME HE
DIDN'T BUILD A WALL AROUND THE
NURSING HOME, YOU FREAK.
♪ ♪
>> Greg: HAPPY, HAPPY
WEDNESDAY, FAVORITE DAY OF THE
WEEK.
>> I'M NOT BITING.
THEY WENT TO THE MONOLOGUE,
CAPITOL HILL MADE THEM ILL.
IT ACCORDING TO VICE NEWS, WHICH
APPARENTLY STILL EXISTS, THE
MEDIAS STRUGGLING WITH
POST-TRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER
CAUSED BY THE JANUARY 6 BREACH
OF THE CAPITAL.
IN FACT, SOME REPORTERS WON'T
EVEN RETURN TO THE BUILDING,
OTHERS ARE IN THERAPY.
IF ONE LONGTIME REPORTER,
MEANING HE'S OLD, HAD TO RETIRE
SOON AFTER THE ATTACK, AND
OTHERS CAN'T SLEEP.
MAYBE THEY'VE SEEN THEIR
RATINGS.
HE FEELS UNSAFE IN HIS HOUSE.
WHICH IS WEIRD, BECAUSE HE LIVES
IN D.C. WHERE PEOPLE FEEL UNSAFE
WHEN THEY LEAVE THEIR HOUSE.
APPARENTLY SEEING A CLOWN IN THE
VIKING HAT KNOCKING OVER A
BOTTLE OF WHY DON'T IS
TANTAMOUNT TO BEING MAULED BY
ISIS IN YOUR KITCHEN.
THERE MORE THAN DISTRAUGHT THE
KARDASHIANS DURING A SILKEN
SHORTAGE.
AT THE GOD WE HAVEN'T HAD A WAR
ON OUR SOIL YET, HOW WOULD THEY
BE ABLE TO COVER IT?
THERE WOULD BE A RUN ON SCENTED
CANDLES AND DREAM JOURNALS.
WHEN YOU HEAR ABOUT JANUARY 6,
YOU ARE CONVINCED IT'S WORSE
THAN 9/11, PERHAPS IT IS, BUT TO
THEM.
>> TO ME, THERE WAS LESS LOSS OF
LIFE ON JANUARY 6TH, JANUARY 6TH
WAS WORSE THAN 9/11 BECAUSE IT'S
CONTINUED TO RIP OUR COUNTRY
APART AND GIVE PERMISSION FOR
PEOPLE TO PURSUE AUTOCRATIC
MEANS.
I THINK WE ARE IN A MUCH WORSE
PLACE THAN WE'VE BEEN IN.
I THINK WE ARE THE MOST PERILOUS
POINT IN TIME SINCE 1861 AND THE
ADVENT OF THE CIVIL WAR.
>> Greg: HE IS JUST BAD TO
[BLEEP] CRAZY.
TO HIM, IT WAS WORSE THAN 9/11,
TELL IT TO THE FAMILIES OF THE
9/11 FIRST RESPONDERS YOU
[BLEEP].
A SORRY, OUR MEDIA.
THEY NEVER BEEN GOOD AT
PRIORITIES, A GROUP OF LARGELY
UNARMED HOUSEWIVES AND DADS WALK
INTO THE CAPITAL, SOMEHOW THAT'S
WORSE THAN THREE PLANES FLYING
INTO BUILDINGS KILLING
THOUSANDS.
I CONDEMN WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6TH, I SAID WHEN
BARBARIANS ARE AT THE GATE, THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE TO BE THE GATE,
NOT THE BARBARIANS.
THAT DAY THEY WENT.
AT THE MEDIAS BEATING THE STORY
TO DEATH LIKE IT'S A TEENAGER
CAUGHT SHOPLIFTING BECAUSE IT'S
A NICE DISTRACT HER FROM THE
HORRIBLE LEAP THEY'VE CAUSED
OVER THE LAST DECADE.
THE CRIME, VIOLENCE, THE
POISONED EDUCATION SYSTEM.
A JANUARY 6 IS THEIR SHIELD FROM
BLAME.
I WONDER WHAT THE ANGRY WHITE
MALE THANKS.
THINKS.
♪ ♪
>> HEY GUYS, ONE MORE TIME?
SURE, WHY NOT.
THIS IS ME, THIS IS MY BRAIN.
THIS IS THE MEDIA.
THIS IS ME WATCHING STORIES THAT
THE MEDIA DOES ABOUT THEMSELVES.
ANY QUESTIONS?
COME ON, YOU'VE GOT QUESTIONS,
DON'T YOU?
I GOT QUESTIONS.
>> Greg: HE NEVER TAKES
QUESTIONS.
I WONDER WHAT THE ANGRY BLACK
MALE THINKS.
♪ ♪
>> GO TO SLEEP.
>> Greg: THE BEST ADVICE, THE
BEST ADVICE IF YOU CAN'T SLEEP.
I'M WONDERING, DID ANY OF THESE
REPORTERS EXPERIENCE ANY
PSYCHOLOGICAL TRAUMA DURING THE
RIOTS OF LAST YEAR?
OTHER THAN HAVING TO READ OR
WATCH THEIR OWN WORK.
IT YOU KNOW WHO DID SUFFER
TRULY?
THE VICTIMS OF THE RIOTS, THE
PEOPLE WHO OWNED STORES AND
HOMES THAT BURNED TO THE GROUND.
IT THE MEDIA SEEMS DETACHED FROM
ALL OF THAT.
WHO CAN FORGET THIS DELIGHTFUL
MOMENT?
SPEAK I WANT TO BE CLEAR AND HOW
I CHARACTERIZE THIS, THIS IS A
PROTEST, AND IS NOT GENERALLY
SPEAKING UNRULY.
AT THE FIRES HAVE BEEN STARTED,
AND THE CROWD IS RELISHING THAT.
>> Greg: IT'S JUST TOO EASY.
AT THE CROWDS WEREN'T THE ONLY
ONES RELISHING IT TO.
MEANWHILE, THE CRIME SPREES THAT
FOLLOWED WERE DENIED BY
DON LEMON AND JOY AGREED TO
BECAUSE THEY OR THEIR IMAGINARY
FRIENDS DIDN'T EXPERIENCE IT
FIRSTHAND.
WHAT A GREAT JOURNALISM GIG,
REPORT ON WHAT PERSONALLY
HAPPENS TO YOU, THEN YOU NEVER
HAVE TO DO ANYTHING.
WHY THE HYSTERIA OVER JANUARY 6
AND OPPOSED TO THE ONGOING
VIOLENCE IN PORTLAND, ATLANTA,
L.A., NEW YORK, SEATTLE?
THE CRIME SPIKES COULDN'T BE
USED POLITICALLY BECAUSE OF THE
RACIAL COMPONENT, BUT THE
JANUARY 6 MOB WAS WIDER THAN THE
DAVE MATTHEWS BAND MAKING SNOW
ANGELS.
AND THAT IS WHITE.
THEY TRY TO TIE IT TO A PHANTOM
WHITE A CU MOVEMENT.
LET'S LOOK AT THE SKY FROM
JANUARY 6.
DOES THIS GUY LOOK LIKE AN
EMBLEM OF WHITE WHITE SUPREMACY.
LOOK AT HIS FACE, THAT'S THE
OPPOSITE OF SUPREMACY.
HE'S BEEN IN JAIL FOR SIX
MONTHS, THAT'S WAY LESS THAN THE
LOOTERS AND ARSONISTS WHO MADE A
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN DAMAGES.
AND NO ACTORS OR POLITICIANS
BOTHERED TO BAIL HIM OUT, HE
DIDN'T EVEN SET FIRE TO
ANYTHING.
HIS WORST CRIME WAS SCARING
NANCY PELOSI, BUT THEN HER
EYEBROWS ALWAYS LOOK LIKE THAT.
CLEARLY, THE GUY IS UNWELL, AS
SICK AS MATTHEW DOWD, BUT NO ONE
CARES, HE'S NO POLITICAL HERO.
HE WON'T BE ON MSNBC SPEWING
NONSENSE ABOUT 9/11.
NOT ONLY DO THEY NOT CARE ABOUT
THE SUSPECTS, THE MEDIA CREATES
A NARRATIVE THAT IT'S A DEADLY
INSURRECTION CAUSED BY THE BIG
LIE, BUT THE BIG LIE WAS
ACTUALLY THERE FOR YEARS PUSHING
OF THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION
DELUSION.
WHEN AN UNARMED PROTESTER GETS
KILLED, THAT'S PAR FOR THE
COURSE.
IMAGINE IF IT WAS A BLM
PROTESTER AND NOT A TRUMPET.
HOLY.
IT'S NOT SURPRISING HOW THE
MEDIA PLACES, SQUEEZING AS MUCH
JUICE OUT OF ONE EVENT WHILE
IGNORING A CRIME WAVE.
THE RISE IN CRIME IMPLICATE THE
MEDIA AND THE DEMS, THEY CAN'T
TALK ABOUT IT, THEY DENY IT.
TO SOME EVEN LAUGH IT OFF.
>> DEMOCRATIC CITIES ARE IN
CHAOS RIGHT NOW.
IS THIS WHAT YOU WANT FROM
JOE BIDEN?
THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE YOUR
COUNTRY AWAY, THEY ARE TAKING
DOWN THE STRETCH USE.
CRIME IS RISING, IT'S SO BAD.
THEY'RE DEFUNDING POLICE.
IT'S LIKE --
>> Greg: THE ONLY TIME THIS
IDIOT WAS RIGHT ABOUT SOMETHING,
AND HE WAS BEING SARCASTIC.
BY THE WAY, I WONDER IF THEY GET
A ROYALTY EVERY TIME I PLAY THAT
SEGMENT.
AT THIS RATE, DON COULD PROBABLY
BUY HIS CALF IMPLANTS.
AT THE MEDIA ARE THE MOST
EGOCENTRIC FOOLS ON THE PLANET.
ONLY THEY CAN SAY THEY ARE
TRAUMATIZED BY ONE DAY IN
JANUARY WHERE AN UNARMED
PROTESTER DIED AS THEY IGNORE
CRIME AROUND THEM EVERY DAY.
IF THEY DIDN'T SEE IT, THEN IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN.
ESPECIALLY IF THAT HAPPENED TO
YOU.
♪ ♪
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUEST!
HE'S CRUSHED MORE ROLES THAN A
HOT DOG EATING CONTEST, ACTOR
DANIEL ROEBUCK BED HE STARTED
THREE NEW COMPANIES IN THE TIME
IT TOOK ME TO READ THIS, AUTHOR
OF THE GREAT NEW BOOKS
"WOKE INC.," VIVEK RAMASWAMY.
SHE HAS A HEART OF GOLD, WHICH
SHE SHOPLIFTED FOR MACY'S,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
AND ALL-YOU-CAN-EAT BUFFET AS
TIRES INSURANCE.
ON FOX NATION, TYRUS.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW, HAVEN'T
SEEN YOU IN A WHILE.
>> NICE TO SEE YOU, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
JUST BE WHEN HE'S THE ALLENTOWN.
THERE ARE ABOUT 100 PEOPLE
GOING, YES.
DO YOU THINK THIS COMPARES TO
MAKE SENSE?
9/11 TO JANUARY 6?
>> I THINK IT'S A BIT OF AN
INSULT TO MANY PEOPLE WHO
PERISHED.
LOOK, I ASKED HIM WHAT HE HAS
PTSD, LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT.
WHEN WE START SETTING, I HAVE
PTSD BECAUSE THERE WAS A GOOSE
THAT WALKED IN FRONT OF MY CAR,
I THINK THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO REALLY SUFFER FROM THIS,
PEOPLE WHO SUFFER FROM RATE AND
ALL THESE TERRIBLE THINGS, AND
THEY HAVE IT, BUT IS THIS REAL?
>> IF YOU GET PTSD FROM A GOOSE,
YOU CAN MAKE THE GOOSE YOUR
THERAPY ANIMAL.
THAT SOLVES TWO PROBLEMS.
IT'S A GOOD POINT.
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN OKAY WITH
THESE, I DON'T KNOW WHY I PICKED
THEM.
>> GEESE ARE HORRIBLE.
JUST BE WHEN THEY ARE TERRIBLE
CREATURES.
SWANS ARE WORSE.
>> THEY LOOK PRETTY, BUT --
>> Greg: THEY USE THEIR NECKS
TO STRANGLE OTHER BIRDS.
>> IS THAT TRUE?
>> Greg: I MADE IT UP, BUT I
LEARNED IF I SAY THINGS WITH
FORCE PEOPLE WILL BELIEVE ME.
>> WORKED ON ME.
>> AND ARE FILTHY RICH, DIRTY
RICH.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT YOUR BOOK,
YOUR BOOK IS GOING TO BE -- IT'S
ALL ABOUT HOW SOCIAL JUSTICE HAS
INFILTRATED CORPORATIONS ON
THEIR USING IT AS A SHIELD FOR
NEFARIOUS BEHAVIOR.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
AT MY PARENTS HAD AN ARRANGED
MARRIAGE, PEOPLE PUT THEM
TOGETHER, KNEW THEM, MET EACH
OTHER WITHIN A WEEK THEY WERE
MARRIED.
THAT WAS ONE THAT WORKED.
THE BOOK IS ABOUT AN ARRANGED
MARRIAGE GONE AWRY.
IT'S LIKE MUTUAL WHERE YOU HAVE
THE WOKE LEFT AND BIG BUSINESS,
NEITHER OF WHOM LOVES ONE
ANOTHER, THEY LOOK DOWN ON ONE
ANOTHER, BUT THEY GOT MARRIED
ANYWAY BECAUSE EACH WAS ABLE TO
DO WHAT THE OTHER COULDN'T
ALONE.
THE ONE THAT'S NOT AN ARRANGED
MARRIAGE.
WE JUMP INTO THAT THING.
>> GET MYSELF IN TROUBLE
TONIGHT.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
HOW AT THE MEDIA LOOK AT THESE
TWO INSTANCES OF RAMPANT CRIME
IN ONE DAY AND A MOB?
>> THIS IS CLASSIC MEDIA
HYPOCRISY.
IF THERE WAS ONE POINT IN THERE
THAT I WANT TO TAKE A VALID
POINT, I DON'T THINK IT'S WHAT
THEY MEANT, BUT THE REACTION
ACTUALLY FRIGHTENS ME MORE THAN
THE REACTION AFTER 9/11, AFTER
9/11, AND I SPEAK AS A MOM WAS
CIVIL LIBERTARIAN INSTEX COME I
DIDN'T LIKE WITH THE
MILITARY-INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX
CREATING A SURVEILLANCE STATE
THAT HAS HAUNTED US FOR 20
YEARS.
THAT'S THE MILITARY-INDUSTRIAL
COMPLEX.
THAT'S NOT AS BAD AS THE BOOK
INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX, WHICH
INVOLVES PRIVATE COMPANIES, NO
CONSTITUTIONALLY UNCONSTRAINED,
AS THAT IS THE
MILITARY-INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX
ONES, AT LEAST IT WAS
CONSTRAINED BY THIS THING CALLED
THE CONSTITUTION.
NOW, THESE GUYS IN GOVERNMENT
ARE ABLE TO GIVE THEIR DIRTY
WORK TO THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND
SAY, THEY ARE WORKING AS PRIVATE
COMPANIES, THAT'S MORE
DANGEROUS.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
THEY ARE PRIVATE INDUSTRY SO
THEY CAN DO WHATEVER THEY WANT.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> I AM PHENOMENAL, GREG.
I'M HOOD RICH, IT'S ALL WORKING
OUT.
HE'S A FRIEND OF YOURS THAT FREE
WHISKEY.
BECAUSE THE AMOUNT OF TIMES THAT
MAN HAS GOT YOU DRUNK.
>> BROUGHT YOU BOOTS, YOUR
MOTHER LOVES YOU AND THIS IS HOW
YOU TREAT THEM?
YOU, GREG GUTFELD.
SPEAKING OF, CAN WE JUST CALL
THIS WHAT THIS IS?
HOW MANY REPORTERS WERE HELD
HOSTAGE IN JANUARY 6?
NONE.
IF MIKE PENCE IS OKAY, ISN'T HE?
THEY WERE LITERALLY CALLING
SAYING THEY WERE GOING TO COME
GET HIM.
THE NEWS WAS FOR PENS, AND HE'S
DOING STAND-UP NOW, HE'S DOING
FINE.
>> Greg: YOU GOT CHUCKLES OUT
OF WESTHAVEN.
>> THE POINT IS, JANUARY 6 WAS
BAD, HERE'S THE AWESOME THING,
THE FBI CAUGHT THE BAD GUYS,
THEY'RE GOING TO JAIL, NOW
THEY'RE GOING TO CATCH MORE.
THAT'S KIND OF SOLVED.
WE DON'T NEED A PANEL THAT,
EVERY TIME THE SENATE -- WE ARE
GOING TO GET A COMMITTEE
TOGETHER, WHY?
YOU HAD A COMMITTEE WITH RUSSIA
AND YOU CAME BACK WITH -- COULD
BE, COULD NOT.
>> I HAD A COMMITTEE FOR KENNEDY
BECAUSE THEY HAD ONE GUY'S HOME
MOVIE THAT LASTED 14 SECONDS.
WE NEED MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
THIS.
>> WE HAVE TOO MUCH.
>> THEY'RE LIKE, RUN THOSE FOUR,
WE HAVE 4 MILLION CAMERAS COME
AROUND THAT.
>> THEY ARE STILL HOPING FOR
THAT TIGHT BOMB, THAT SOMEHOW
WILL IMPLICATE PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE LITERALLY TRIED EVERYTHING,
THE FBI DIDN'T QUESTION HIM
BECAUSE IT WASN'T ABOUT HIM.
THEY KNEW WHO DID IT, WHO
PLANNED IT, AND THEY'VE ARRESTED
THEM.
IF THEY WANT WHAT HAPPENED TO
THE PIPE BOMBS?
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
>> THEY GOT THEM AHEAD OF TIME
AND FOUND THEM OR WHATEVER.
THE POINT IS, THAT MYSTERY IS
SOLVED, WE DIDN'T HAVE TO LOOK
FOR WHO DID IT, WE HAVE IT ON
FILM WHO DID IT.
THEY DRESSED UP IN RIDICULOUS
OUTFITS, THEY WERE PRETTY EASY
TO SPOT THE FOLLOWING DAY.
>> Greg: THEY WERE THE
OPPOSITE OF ANTIFA.
THEY SPEND ALL THEIR TIME TRYING
TO HIDE THEIR FACES WHILE THEY
HURT PEOPLE, THESE GUYS WERE
SHOWING UP FOR WHO THEY WERE
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT THEY WERE
TRYING TO -- THEY WERE TRYING TO
CHANGE THE CONSTITUTION, THOUGHT
THEY WERE TRYING TO SAY THAT,
THEY WERE WRONG.
>> OBVIOUSLY, WE'VE ALL
CONDEMNED IT SO MANY TIMES, BUT
IN THESE INTERVIEWS THERE'S BEEN
NO ACCOUNTABILITY.
I HAVEN'T HEARD ANYONE WHO IS
REALLY FAILED CONDEMN IT THAT I
KNOW, AND ALSO AS YOU MENTIONED,
400 PEOPLE AND FROM 40 DIFFERENT
STATES HAVE BEEN ARRESTED
ALREADY, SO I THINK THAT GOING
TO JAIL IS ACCOUNTABILITY.
I THINK IT IS.
IN GENERAL, I JUST THINK IT'S
BAD TO COMPARE ANYTHING TO 9/11.
IT'S JUST BAD FORM.
I'M NOT GOING TO SAY THAT, --
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE.
ANALOGIES ARE A PROBLEM BECAUSE
THEY ARE NEVER O